[Music]
in chapter 13 of her fourth earthsea
novel to hanu ursula k le guin narrates
a set of encounters between a mother and
her son who has come back from applying
his fear of being a sailor
on a ship that has a disreputable
function perhaps a pirate ship perhaps
not as we're going to see
and the reason why this is such an
important encounter is because her son
spark
is really a stand-in for
a sort of failure
of manhood in in this story and tenor
takes it to heart as her own failure and
i think that you know in large respect
the novel to hanu
thematizes the relations between women
and men and we can see spark in so many
other people not only in the earth's
universe but even in our own cultures as
well
so a bit of backstory here first tenar
who is the main character in the second
novel
uh who's from the kargish lands she's
actually a priestess arha the eaten one
she regains her name back
ged and her managed to escape to reunite
the ring of ereth akbar which holds out
the possibility of restoring a kind of
unity and and order and function to
earth see
and then she stays after they go to
hovnor and present the ring she comes
back to gant stays with ged's old
teacher ogian and then decides on a life
for herself taking a name a use name
goha
she marries the farmer flint
and she has two children a daughter
apple and a son
spark these being of course their use
names not their their true names
apple ends up marrying and she is a
important secondary character in this
story she meets her mother
at the port when her mother
tenor is coming in on the great ship
with the king
and she's you know sort of a stable
character
spark however goes off to sea and at the
time that the novel begins tenor hasn't
seen him for for years he doesn't even
know that his father has died years back
flint himself will die on the farm and
tenor will tell that story to
spark so she becomes the widow gohan and
she manages the farm as that widow and
that's where the story begins and she
still has that status when spark returns
early on in
chapter 13.
so
i'm going to read a little bit of this
even with ged to help her all her
thoughts and days went into the business
of the farm he shared the housework with
her as flint had not but flint had been
a farmer and get was not he learned fast
but there was a lot to learn they worked
there was a little time for talk now at
the day's end there was supper together
and bed together and sleep and wake at
dawn and back to work and so round and
round like the wheel of a water mill
rising full and emptying the days like
the bright water follow following and so
this is a a very nice routine for
ged and tenor who have known each other
since he was a young man and she was a
girl and
finally have
gotten together right
he's pretending essentially to be a
farmhand
then we have something happen hello
mother said the thin fellow at the
farmyard gate she thought it was lark's
eldest and said what brings you by lad
then she looked back at him across the
clucking chickens in the parading geese
spark she cried and scattered the
poultry running to him well well he said
don't carry on he let her embrace him
and stroke his face he came down and sat
down in the kitchen at the table have
you eaten did you see apple i could eat
she rummaged in the well stocked larder
what ship are you on still the gull
no a pause my ships broke up
she turned in horror wrecked
no he smiled without humor crews broke
up king's men took her over
but it wasn't a pirate ship no then why
said the captain was running some goods
they wanted he said unwillingly he was
thin as ever but looked older tan dark
land haired with a long narrow face like
flint's but still narrower
harder so
we've got this you know homecoming and
it seems kind of nice at first
and then there's a little bit of
reticence a little bit of foreboding he
was on a ship
and something sketchy was happening it's
not a pirate ship as such but
there's a reason why the king's men
broke up the crew and why he's back in
town
and then he asked where's dad tenor
stood still you didn't stop by your
sisters
no he said indifferent
flint died three years ago she said of a
stroke in the fields on the path up from
the lambing pens clear brook found him
it was three years ago
and so
you know he's kind of indifferent to
things he doesn't talk much you notice
that in the sentences he doesn't even
speak in full sentences he's a person
who's unwilling to give things and he's
being very cagey about what's going on
he asks so who's been running the farm
what's that to you son she asked him
gently but dryly
it's mine he said in a rather similar
tone
after a minute tener got up and cleared
his dishes away so it is
you can stay of course he said very
awkwardly perhaps attempting to joke but
he was not a joking man and then he
starts asking questions about you know
who's still here who's not so he's
clearly asserting his ownership
over the farm and
ignoring everything that his mother
has done along with all the other people
and just thinking about how it's his
tenor thinks that he's like his father
she asks him a question and this is kind
of a revelatory
incident he says are you here for a stay
then
i might be
so flint had answered her questions for
20 years denying her right to ask them
by never answering yes or no maintaining
a freedom based on her ignorance a poor
narrow sort of freedom she thought and
we see this with so many people they
they have a need to preserve their own
little
tawdry freedom their own little petty
freedom and they do so by
not behaving like a decent human being
engaging with other people speaking
straightly with them allowing them to
make plans allowing them to
engage you in a relationship it's a way
of trying to maintain control
by keeping other people ignorant
there's another thing that's said about
him there as well
that i think is
completely you know
on about him
she says
poor lad your crew broken up your father
dead strangers in your house all in a
day you'll want some time to get used to
it i'm sorry my son but i'm glad you're
here i thought of you often on the seas
and the storms in winter she's behaving
towards him as a
parent
he said nothing
he had nothing to offer
and was unable
to accept
that is
revelatory of the kind of person we're
dealing with
he has nothing to give
he accepts nothing
again trying to maintain his own
freedom
against other people and it kind of
solitude and
loneliness what he does expect however
is to be served and there's also an
incident there where
he's very scottish and skeptical about
pharaoh being his sister a sister by
adoption he he can't see what everybody
else can see
in there
but he does expect to be served he
wanted breakfast the next day and
expected it to be served to him his
father how had been waited on by mother
wife daughter was he less a man than his
father was she to prove it to him
she served him his meal and cleared it
away from him and went back to the
orchard
and spark goes off to to join clear
brook and tiff and he stayed mostly with
them as the day
passed the heavy work requiring muscle
and the skilled work with crops and
sheep was done by ged shandy and tenor
while the two old men who'd been there
all their lives his father's men took
him about and told them how they managed
it all and truly believed they were
managing it all and shared their belief
with him so what we have are the guys
and they're not really doing any real
work and then we have ged and the the
women who are doing the real work of the
farm and this should be a familiar
picture for so many of us not just with
farms but households businesses it
doesn't necessarily have to be men and
women but
i would say men are a little bit more
prone to this unless they are
in
certain institutions ged has been a mage
you know we might think of other cases
where men will take on work and not call
it women's work
for instance when i was in the army if
you try to tell people that cooking
cleaning
ironing all those sorts of things were
women's work and you weren't going to do
it
these very very tough men would look at
you as if you're insane because it's not
women's work it's work and the same
thing for a
farm so what we have here is a young man
who is
rather entitled who doesn't have a lot
to offer and who hangs out with the
other people who don't as well
tenor
comes to feel anger about this but she
also feels
shame
shame at how her
young man spark has turned out her
daughter has turned out to be quite a
decent person
spark is not
and what we see
in this this discussion
is
she in a way
tests him
right the next morning spark was up
early to breakfast with him for he was
going fishing with old tiff
he got up from the table saying with a
better grace than usual i'll bring a
mess of fish for for supper tenor had
made resolves overnight she said wait
you can clear off the table spark set
the dishes in the sink and put water on
them they'll be washed with the supper
things notice what she's
not saying you have to wash the dishes
just
pick up your dishes
put them in the sink put a little water
on them very trivial thing to do
he won't do it
why not
he says that's women's work
and she says it's anybody's work who
eats in this kitchen
not mine he said flatly and went out
she followed him so she's going to press
the issue
hawks meaning good but not yours
he merely nodded going on across the
yard and she says to herself it's too
late
failed
failed she can feel the lines in her
face stiff beside the mouth between the
eyes you can water a stone but it won't
grow
god says you have to start them when
they're young and tender like me because
at 15 years old he was already doing
those things as a matter of fact with
ogi and there wasn't any oh that's
women's work to do either right
spark refuses to do
the most trivial things
and gohar tenor
says to gad a little bit earlier
my turn my turn to lose what i was
proudest of
gad says what have you lost my son
the son i did not bring up to be a man i
failed i failed him
ged did not try to argue with her
persuade her out of her grief he asked
do you think he'll stay
and she says yes he's afraid to try to
go back to see he didn't tell me the
truth or not all the truth about his
ship he was second mate i suppose he was
involved in carrying stolen goods
second-hand piracy i don't care
conscious sailors are all half pirate
but he lies about it he lies he's
jealous of you a dishonest envious man
so she's seeing her son
as somebody who came from her who she
raised but has turned into a failure
as a man a failure in in many respects
it's not just the entitlement and
unwillingness to do women's work you
know labeling things as beneath him
expecting to be waited on
it's also the lying lying to the people
that he should be
least lying to his own
family
he's
got no center he has no as we say moral
compass and you can't rely on him for
anything and this produces a grief a a
shame a
anger on her part now ged tries to put a
good face on it he says frightened i
think
and not wicked and it is his farm
and she says then he can have it it may
be as generous to him as and she's
cursing him and gad says no dear love
don't speak don't say the evil word
he was so urgent so passionately earnest
that her anger turned right about into
the love that was its source
and she cried i wouldn't curse him or
this place i didn't mean it
only it makes me so sorry so ashamed i
am so sorry god
dad says no no no my dear i don't care
what the boy thinks of me but he's very
hard on you and she says and pharaoh he
treats her like he said to me what did
she do to look like that what did she
do
and they talk about going off together
perhaps goat hurting or something like
that because they're not going to stay
there then something forces the issue
moss is sick she needs to be taken care
of uh up by by ogian
and so they
they decide that they're going to leave
and
she tells spark will be off to ray albee
first thing tomorrow son hawk and
theroux and i
he looked a little frightened
just go off like that
so you went so you came said his mother
now look here spark this is your
father's money box there's seven ivory
pieces in it and those credit counters
from old bridgeman he'll never pay he's
never got anything to pay with these
four andre and pl pieces flint got from
selling sheepskins to the ship's
outfitter the three havorian ones are
what foley paid us for i had your father
buy that farm and i helped him clear it
and sell it i'll take those three pieces
for i've earned them the rest and the
farm is yours you're the master so
they're leaving now and he says
take it all i don't want it
and she says i don't need it but i thank
you my son keep the four pieces when you
marry
call them my gift to your wife
spark says when are you coming back and
she says
i don't know my dear if you need me i'll
come
spark you can do something for me go see
your sister and tell her i've been to
the i've gone back to the overfell if
she wants me to send word so she is
giving him what he wants
but he doesn't want it the way that
she's giving it he asserted ownership
over the farm but he assumed that she
would just stay there waiting on him
hand and foot and instead she's going to
move on with
her life
she reminds him that
you left like this i can leave like this
as well
she's being very
fair with him and he is
taking it about as well
as he can
there's not really a solid relationship
there and
is it is it tenar's fault that he turned
out the way that he did perhaps she
bears
some responsibility but probably not
he's a grown man
he decides what he does and what his
character will be
so
this is a very interesting vignette that
we see and leguin is telling us
something about
men and earthsea and men in our own
world through presenting spark in this
way
you